- [Interviewer] I hate
hearing these stories of
girls getting taken advantage of.
- It's basically all it is
is mastermind manipulation.
They find your weakness and
they use it against you.
They use your emotions,
you know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] So what gets women
into these relationships with,
they're not really pimps
they're more gang members
that are just realizing
they can exploit what girls
are doing on the street.
- It's not even gang members.
It's just men,
I feel maybe who had past
experience with women,
mommy issues, or something.
And...
- [Interviewer] But now
they're functioning like pimps
'cause they're taking the
money that you guys make.
- Yeah, but they don't
call themselves pimps
but they use the pimp mentality
in order to get what it is that they want.
It's not like they have
holes on the corner.
And then, you know, riding around like how
what pimps usually do.
They could just be regular guys
manipulating women,
womanizing to get what it is they want
regardless if they use
regards if they use sex or
money, not money, sex or
love
Just basically anything
that draws a woman to a man.
- [Interviewer] To lure you in.
- To lure you in.
- [Interviewer] And once you're
kind of attached to them...
- Once they know that they have you,
they they'll test you.
They'll do little things to see,
you know what I'm saying, how you react.
And once they see that
they're getting the
reaction that they want
or you're responding how they want,
they know they got you.
And a person can only do
to you what you allow them.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- So if you keep allowing it,
they're gonna keep doing it,
but just gets worse and worse.
- [Interviewer] But there
seems to be a lot of the young
girls that are
victims of this.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Then
taken an advantage of,
and they let it go on
and they're hoping for something better,
but it's never gonna happen.
- And ain't never happens.
And if it does this definition of sanity.
Doing the same thing over and over,
maybe with different people.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- But always expecting different results.
And the results always the same.
- [Interviewer] Maybe some of the ladies
will watch these videos and figure it out.
(chuckles)
- Yeah.
The logic in knowing and
comprehending what's going on
or what if somebody is doing to you
and still doing the same
thing or allowing it to happen
it's insane.
- [Interviewer] And then they'll
get the girls addicted to
meth or crack or whatever.
- Cause that's what happened to me.
I was in a relationship,
but at the time with a female.
I was a dancer.
She used to work for the refinery,
lost her job for whatever the reason.
I said, "Okay, don't worry
about nothing, I got it."
I paid the bills.
I took care of her, her daughter.
And it got to a point where I
didn't know she was in drugs.
But,
she told me,
one day she was like, "I
need some more money."
And it's like, how do
you need some more money?
I just gave you $500,
you know what I'm saying?
Sometimes I'll give her seven, eight.
Well, it depends on how good I do.
I didn't happen to winter
but I give her something.
And,
it's like, "Where's your money going?
You don't have to pay for nothing.
So what are you doing?"
And I told her, I said,
"Your money, that the money
I gave you is your money.
What's in my pockets is mine.
You can't control or dictate none of that.
I don't have to give nothing,
but what I want to give you."
And that's what triggered it.
So she got me started on
drugs and she used- love,
she played on my emotions.
My trust for her
in order to give me to do it.
Because you would never
think somebody who loves you
or cares about you
will sit here and bring such a
demonic demon into your life.
But she did.
And I know this because years
later she admitted it to me
'cause I asked her like,
"Why did you do this?"
And she told me just like,
how I said is exactly what she told me.
It pissed her off.
- [Interviewer] So at some
point living this lifestyle
where everyone's taking
advantage of everybody
and it's just you're disappointed
on a daily basis, right?
Do you ever just like go,
"What the fuck?
Let me get out of here?"
- Every day.
- [Interviewer] But what
stops you from doing it?
'Cause you've been doing
it for how long now?
- For too long.
For way too long.
- [Interviewer] A lot of
people would watch this video
and go like, "Just to get out."
- It's not that easy to say,
"Hey, okay, I'm gonna get out."
If it was that easy, you
know what I'm saying?
People will do it.
It's easier said than done.
It's hard
- [Interviewer] Cause of how you do it,
how support yourself, how you...
- It's not even about supporting yourself.
It's the mental damage,
the emotional damage
the spiritual damage.
That shit weighs on you.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
because your self worth
gets beaten down by
living this life, right?
- Yeah, all the way down.
You feel broken inside.
And all this pain and
hurt this inside of you,
it's like every day you try to numb it.
- [Interviewer] That's what
I think a lot of people
don't understand is how
destructive this lifestyle
is to your psyche, to your self worth.
- It is, it is.
And every day it gets
worse and worse and worse.
- [Interviewer] And you
guys might look beautiful.
You're dressed nicely and
you're certainly very attractive
but your self-worth is in the gutter.
And you're doing these things
and giving all the money to
some stranger or some guy
that's lying to you and
cheating and doing everything.
And you put up with it.
Whereas most people would be like,
"No, just do the right thing and get out."
But you're so broken that
you can't, is that it?.
- You're right it's
some things that they do
they keep you trapped.
Something, they keep, hold over your head.
And then it's like,
the mental just
manipulation.
'Cause they make you feel
like it's your fault.
They twist things to make
it feel like it's you,
it's you, it's you.
And then that makes you
wanna run to the drugs
because you're tryna numb it.
You're tryna get away.
'Cause that's the only thing
that gets you out your head.
And I know it sounds crazy
or it sounds like an excuse,
but it's the reality.
- [Interviewer] How many of
the girls are addicted to
crack or meth down there.
A hundred percent?
- I've never met anybody who wasn't.
- [Interviewer] Right.
That's the answer.
- Even people outside this lifestyle.
- [Interviewer] They told me they used to
but the truth is they still are.
- And it's like, everybody
has an addiction,
drugs,
money,
shopping,
gambling,
coffee, cigarettes.
Everybody has an addiction.
So nobody's really any
better than anybody else
because it's not about
what they're addicted to,
it's the feeling or the
mental of being addicted.
It's like, it's hard for
some people to stop drinking
or stop smoking cigarettes.
Or you know what I'm saying?
With coffee, some people can't
even function in the morning
unless they have their coffee.
"Don't talk to me, I
haven't had my coffee"
So,
it's hard.
Some things are easier to deal with.
Some things affect you differently
like coffee or cigarettes is not gonna,
cause you to go through
things that most other people
go through addicted to other things.
But,
in a way they're all
- [Interviewer] Destructive.
- Yeah.
Smoking cigarettes, you
know what I'm saying?
It's bad for your health.
Coffee's bad for you.
All this stuff is bad for you.
- [Interviewer] I'm hoping that
if enough women watched my
prostitute and pimp videos,
they'll eventually figure out
how much of a trap this life is.
- It is, it's a trap.
And sometimes you get
trapped without even knowing.
- [Interviewer] No,
you're walking into it
going, "This feels good."
- Especially if you're
not from the environment
or it's created or where it's at.
Like, I'm not from LA.
So when I came, like I
said, when I came out here
it was like a movie like, "Oh my gosh.
Boys in the hood," or something like that.
So, it's this excitement,
'cause always looks
shiny in the beginning.
I'm not saying the prostitution part,
all that comes later on.
But you meet some people
and they seem a certain way.
You're like, "Oh, okay."
And that comes from bad
judgment and character.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about your father.
- My dad,
he was a good man.
He was the first black man
to make it to nationals in the HRA.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So, your
dad was a stand up guy.
- Yeah, my dad left a legend.
- [Interviewer] You had
a good father figure.
- Yeah, but he wasn't,
he was there physically but emotionally
he wasn't.
Financially he was,
but as far as being able
to teach me and groom me
to know what type of man
I'm supposed to be with
or what I should allow it and not allow,
I didn't get that.
I lacked that, the love, the affection,
I lacked that.
So, as I got older, I
was looking for that.
But the places I was looking for,
it was all the wrong places.
And when people learn your weaknesses
or what it is that you lack
or what it is that you like or
what is you want,
they use that against you.
And...
- [Interviewer] Are any of
these women saving money
with their pimps?
- Are they doing what?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, they're
making a lot of money.
They claim to be making a
thousand a night or whatever.
Are any of them actually saving money?
- Some do.
I had a home girl that,
she was putting a little bit to the side,
and it was the same thing.
She was in a relationship.
She met her dude.
He wasn't her chick before.
And they got in a relationship
and then he turned into this pimp
or whatever.
And I used to watch like,
he would start an argument with her.
If he didn't have anything
any drugs or money,
he would just just start
an argument out of nowhere
and just start talking to her.
"Are you doing this.
Or you have some guy in
the house, are you fuck?"
Just all kinds of shit.
Just to get under her skin.
Just to make her wanna chase,
what it is to medicate
and to numb the bulshit.
- [Interviewer] But she was saving money.
- She was.
But it took a long time for
her to break that cycle.
It took a while.
She was the breadwinner.
She was paying the bills and all that.
But he would throw, "This is my place."
this then the other and blah, blah, blah.
But she's like,
"Hey, it's your place
but who's keeping it?"
- [Interviewer] But 99%
of them seem to be...
- Who's keeping it?
- [Interviewer] Going nowhere.
- Yeah, like who's keeping it going.
Who's keeping you in this place.
Only thing you got going
is your name on the lease.
That's it.
Yeah, some do and some don't.
I used to make that
amount when I was dancing.
or when I was working for the post office,
but now,
it's not the same.
Especially with the day-to-day life
and the shit you have to deal with.
But it's like making and
having is two different things.
You might make it, but what do you have?
- [Interviewer] But it
seems like the girls
get into a weaker mental state
after doing this for awhile
than they were when they entered it.
- 'Cause some women
didn't enter it willingly.
They entered it blindly like me.
I entered it in relationship.
And then it just started
turning into something else.
And it's like once you have feelings,
like I'm a Libra and Libras love hard.
So,
once I got,
you know what I'm saying,
my friends got involved,
it's like, things slowly
started unraveling.
Like things were getting
revealed and it's like,
I got caught up.
I didn't know what I was doing
until it was either already done
or I was already in it.
- [Interviewer] And now
you are using crack.
- Now I use cocaine, I smoke weed.
I'm not a big drinker, but yeah.
And this is not something that
I ever thought I would do.
And it's crazy because I
just started dating men.
I stopped dating men at the age of 17,
I started back at the age of 31.
I dealt with women all
majority of my life.
So, me not knowing really
how to deal with a man
and handle them.
Yeah.
So when they get aggressive,
it's like I don't know how to
handle that aggressiveness.
I'm not gonna sit here and fight a man.
I have two broke fingers from that.
This one, I have to get
they have to break it
and put it back in place.
This one just was recently.
And,
it's just crazy.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- My baby daddy...
- [Interviewer] The more
I learn about this life
and what goes on, the
more horrified I get.
- Yeah.
And it's like, I try to do other things.
Like I used to, I used to sell drugs.
I used to boost,
I used to,
shit!
Not saying sell women,
but if somebody came to
me and wanted something,
I knew where to go.
The plug, basically, they used to say.
I could plug you to where
you need what you want
or what you need or where you need to go.
So I done did it all.
You know what I'm saying?
Jack of all trades.
But it's like after a
while it gets tiring.
'Cause, what do I have to show from it?
Besides mental abuse,
physical abuse, spiritual.
What do I have to show for it?
Some people win,
some people lose
and some people just stay
in the middle stagnant.
- [Interviewer] What do
you think would help you
get out now?
You're still young.
- I don't wanna say a divine intervention
but,
a spiritual breakthrough.
Because that's where it
starts at, it's the spirit
and it works its way up.
Once your spirit is strong,
your mind becomes strong.
- [Interviewer] It's it like,
I've heard a lot of pimps say
it's all about mind control.
What they do is they break your spirit,
and then you're defenseless.
You're gonna do whatever
they want for as long as...
- Because, especially once you
become so dependent on them
Because in the beginning
they did everything for you .
In a regular relationship,
you guys go out on dates,
they pay for this, they buy your clothes,
whatever it is you need.
They wine and dine, you give you shelter,
whatever it is.
Then all of a sudden it's ooh,
it's it becomes a struggle.
Or how are we gonna do this?
How are we gonna get this?
How are we gonna wo wo wo?
So then the woman,
being in the back, "Okay baby.
Imma try to do this, Imma try to do that."
And then that's how the ball get started.
And it's fucked up.
And it's like a lot of
the women who enter this,
like me, I was molested at
the age of nine by my cousin.
I was molested at the
age of nine by my cousin.
- [Interviewer] Cousin?
- Yeah.
And it was ongoing for awhile.
Even as I got older,
they would try to make passes at me.
But being older,
I was able to be more defensive to...
Okay, like, it's not cool.
But as a child you're trusting.
Especially a family member.
Women trust the men to protect them.
So I'm thinking that this
man, who's my family member
wouldn't do nothing to harm me
and how he,
is that manipulation
and it's fucked up.
It's fucked up.
Women we know, men want
to be treated as kings,
whereas a king, you should
treat me as a queen.
But when you treat me as a peasant,
I'll do peasant things.
And,
it's crazy the way it is.
- [Interviewer] It's like
these girls get brainwashed.
- It's brainwash.
And people were like
passed judgment so quick.
You can't pass judgment on nothing
that you have not went through,
felt, experienced
or endured.
You haven't walked in my shoes,
you can't say nothing to me.
You can not judge me.
The only thing you can do is feel for me.
Other than that,
your opinion is,
It means nothing to me.
Because how can,
that's like if somebody's mother passed
and I say,
"Oh, I understand."
"Or I'm sorry." You know what I'm saying?
I feel, how can you understand
what I'm going through
and you've never went through it?
Your mother's still alive.
So how can you tell me
you understand what I'm going through
and you've never felt it.
How can you sit here and tell me,
"Oh I need to do this then the other,"
and you've never done what I've done.
How can you advise me
on something that you
can't even understand?
So, until you walked the path I walked,
it's like you can't judge me.
Only person who can judge
me first of all is God.
And clearly nobody's God.
So until you've done that,
if you can't motivate or
be inspiring or helping,
just stay away.
Keep your comments to yourself.
Because you don't know me,
you don't know my story,
we're all books.
We're all books.
People judge the covers of the books
without even getting into
the chance to read the story.
But if you want to know
me to be able to judge me
or understand me, read my story.
In order for you to read my story,
you have to listen,
understand,
comprehend
take heath
to what it is I'm showing you, telling you
or what I'm
presenting you.
"Cause you can read a person.
You can understand the person
but you have to pay attention.
Don't judge me off of what you see.
Judge me off of what you hear from me.
What you see from me.
You see, there's fictional
books in there and the facts.
Some people will give
you a fictional story.
And there's some people
who give you the facts.
So sometimes it is hard
to know who a person is
or who they are or the
type of character they are.
Because they'll play a role.
They'll put a facade,
for you to see them the way
they want you to see them
or for you to
fall into whatever the lies or whatever is
the motive they have,
or even display this false character.
I take people at face value.
'Cause,
who am I for you to lie to me?
Show me who you are and
I'll show you who I am.
And at that point we can decipher if
we want to do with each other
that's it doesn't have to be
in relationship with anybody.
I don't have time to sit here
and be Tom, Dick, Harry,
Larry, Mary, Sarah or whoever
for me to gain anything from me
because that's too much to keep up with.
Accept me for who I am or
don't accept me at all.
And I'm fine with that.
This is me.
Either you accept what I've been through,
what I'm going through, where I'm at
and where I wanna be.
And if you cant help me get from
where I'm at to where I wanna be,
then you're not for me.
People always think that
if they can show something materialistic,
that some people fall for that,
they want the materialist.
I don't care nothing about that.
'Cause all that shit can be replaced.
You can burn a hundred dollar bill
and you be given another one, same one.
This building can burn down,
they can build another one.
Your car can
blow up and you get the
exact same bloody damn car.
Same year, same color, same everything.
But once I'm gone,
you're gone and whoever's gone,
I'll never be replaced, I'm gone.
So, I care about love, honesty,
respect, loyalty, trust
and to be genuine with it.
That's what I want.
You see people take advantage of that.
They don't try to sit here and lure me in
with materialistic things.
They try to lure me in with
a person
that they know
they can never be or they're not,
but by playing the role,
they know they can get
what it is they want.
And it's sex.
- [Interviewer] Alright Trina.
Thank you for the
interesting conversation.
- Thank you.
I hope it helps somebody here.
- [Interviewer] I think it might.
Hopefully these videos
help young girls figure out
what's up and what's not.
- Yeah.
Because,
you gotta love yourself.
You got to know yourself.
You gotta know your self worth.
And
especially after you have lost that,
have lost sight of that,
it's hard to get it back.
But if you want better
for you you have to.
'Cause that's the page I'm on.
I have to want better for me.
'Cause if I don't want
better, I won't have better.
If I want the same thing,
I'll be stagnated where I'm at
and what I'm getting in the
environment that I'm in.
So the change comes within us.
If we don't make a change,
well, nothing change.
You gotta change people,
places and things.
- [Interviewer] Awesome.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] I was great.
(chuckles)
It was really good.
You were awesome.
- Thank you.
- Welcome.
(indistinct), that was a nice influence.